retiro mi nombre de la candidatura
presidencial me retiro de la contienda
lo hago por mi país
así anunció muharrem Inge quien Era uno
de los tres principales candidatos
presidenciales de la oposición turca su
retiro de la contienda el ex candidato
del partido republicano del pueblo un
movimiento secular y de Centro izquierda
denunció calumnias y famacion en su
contra por parte de las autoridades
turcas durante la campaña su retiro
podría remoldear los últimos días antes
de la jornada electoral que es
considerada como la mayor prueba del
presidente ultraconservador regia erdoan
en los 20 años que llevan el poder
muham buscaría impulsar la candidatura
de que Mike principal oponente de erdoan
al acabar con las divisiones en la
oposición sin embargo es optimista con
los resultados del domingo traté de
darle una alternativa a los electores
Pero fracasé cuando la oposición pierda
las elecciones no se iban a culpar no
les demos excusas voto pero me retiro de
la candidatura Gracias a todos
durante un mitin electoral en ankara
erdoan reaccionó al retiro de indiep no
entiendo por qué tomó tal decisión
sinceramente me entristece Hubiera
deseado que continuara hasta el final
pero Seguiremos Nuestro camino con los
otros candidatos lo que importa es la
decisión de mi nación
ha criticado ferozmente la tasa de
inflación del 44% y la respuesta del
gobierno erdoan al devastador terremoto
en febrero en el que murieron más de
50.000